Now, we have a function that depends on two variables.
The temperature depends on time as well as on position.
The typical way to visualize this is to use a 3-dimensional drawing.
For every time and every position, we go up by the value of the function, and so in the end,
we get some kind of curve surfers that describes the function.
The partial derivative with respect to time computes the rate of
change as time increases, but we leave x constant.
The slope of this tangent line is the partial derivative with respect to time.
The partial derivative with respect to x keeps the time constant
and only looks at what happens when we change x towards the slope of such a line.
In the end, it boils down to computing regular derivatives and simply leaving
all the variables fixed that are not mentioned.
If you form the partial derivative with respect to T, we treat x as though it was a constant.
If you form the partial derivative with respect to x, you treat T as though it was a constant.